I find it incredible that scientists can look
at a skull, just the skull… and determine
almost exactly who that person was.
Skulls hold clues to our race, age, and sex.
For example, just from a skull found in the
woods in 1988.
Police were able to solve the case of a young
Asian woman whose husband was ultimately charged
with her murder.
You probably know we all have fingerprints
but no two person’s prints are the same,
skulls are like this too; every individual’s
skull is different.
Your parents determine how your skull is shaped
but your ancestry helps scientists identify
where you came from, and who you are.
Our skulls underlie how we look…
Things like the height of our cheekbones,
and the shape of our jaw determine our facial
features, but those don’t necessarily help
solve cases, they’re called nonmetric features
-- they’re too personal.
But there are some general features all skulls
have that help identify who a skull belonged
to.
One of the first questions anyone would have
looking at a solitary skull is whether it
came from a man or a woman.
Men tend to have larger, thicker, heavier
skulls with a more pronounced ridge here...
in their temporal line, and a more pronounced
ridge over top of the eyes.
Women have a slightly sharper surface on the
edge of their eye socket.
Skulls hold clues to age as well.
The bones that make up the skull are separated
in babies but held together by fibrous bands
of tissue to allow the brain to grow.
These are unique fibrous joints called cranial
sutures.
As we age, the bones grow closer together
and the joints start to fuse.
The older we get, the more the sutures close.
I’m sure someone is already down in the
comments asking about race.
Skulls can reveal a lot about our race as
well, but, like with any of these characteristics
they’re not 100-percent.
In fact, often skulls seem to indicate they
come from more than one racial group.
Humans have evolved different features over
time as we’ve adapted to different environments,
and our skulls show those clues to our ancestry.
Take the nose for example.
The nasal spine, the tiny little bit of bone
that supports the cartilage separating the
nostrils.
In Asian populations, that bone tends to be
of moderate height.
In Caucasian populations, it’s more prominent
and straighter.
In African populations, it’s significantly
smaller or sometimes totally absent.
And shapes of noses differ, too, anthropologists
think because of the climates we evolved in
[re], and this is reflected in the shape and
size of the nasal cavities.
Populations in the cooler climates of Europe
adapted by forming narrower noses to more
efficiently heat inhaled air, while populations
in warmer climates like Africa and South Asia
adapted with broader noses.
And there are other distinguishing factors,
as well!
An oval-shaped window in the inner ear is
seen more in Caucasian populations than Native
American populations.
There are also subtle differences between
populations in the shape of eye orbits, projection
of the lower jaw or forehead, shape and distance
between cheekbones, and forehead.
There is so much you can learn from looking
at the big bone that makes up your face!
Of course, studying a skull alone isn’t
perfect.
The case of the murdered woman hinged on the
skull, but also involved routine police work
and facial reconstruction…
But in any case, knowing a victim’s sex,
age and possible heritage can absolutely help
narrow the search and find a killer.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Of course, there’s more to forensic science,
like DNA evidence, which isn’t always right,
as Trace explains in this video right here.
But, seriously, how cool is this!?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below, be sure to give this video a like,
and subscribe so you never miss an episode
of Seeker.